der Weiterbetrieb der AKW hat keine
Auswirkungen auf den Strompreis
Deutschland hat kein Stromproblem durch
AKW lässt sich fast kein CO2 einsparen
diese Lügen haben uns die Grünen rund um
Robert Habeck aufgetischt um mit dem CO2
Märchen direkt mal aufzuräumen
tatsächlich während des pro Jahr 25 bis
30 Millionen Tonnen CO2 weniger im
deutschen Strommarkt übrigens die
Ministerien für Wirtschaft und Umwelt
hatten die Ablehnung einer
Laufzeitverlängerung weitgehend
vorformuliert und das noch bevor eine
intensive Prüfung des Sachverhalts
stattgefunden hatte das Nein zu längeren
AKW-Laufzeiten stand offenbar sogar im
Widerspruch zu Einschätzungen von
Fachbeamten des Wirtschaftsministeriums
selbst für die weitere Atomdiskussion in
der Energiekrise verheißt das nichts
Gutes es zeigt sich nämlich Ideologie
geht bei den Grünen vor Fakten